ladies and gentlemen boys and girls and
children
of all ages we are one month away
from the adventure of a lifetime the
epic
summer movie going event known as
jungle cruise you guys are excited we
are so excited
the timing of this movie uh getting
released uh couldn't be better as we are
all
trying to get on the other side of covid
and everyone
is going back to the movie theaters it's
an exciting time
so ladies and gentlemen i give you the
newest the greatest
and the latest trailer for jungle cruise
with myself
and my co-star uh uh
what's her uh what's her name essa
every what is it actually i know what it
is it's rhetorical
hey
ladies and gentlemen enjoy jungle cruise
trailer with myself
and ethel brunt in theaters around the
world
in one month enjoy
of all the jungle cruises you could take
in the amazon this one is undoubtedly
the cheapest but also the most thrilling
heads up coming through
look out
marauders
natives
ladies and gentlemen the moment you've
all been waiting for
the backside of water
steve's wonder of the world
anjana frankie boy mr nila please don't
call me that i'm going to keep your
engine
i got my money then you'll get it back
frank gives me money
[Music]
please go away i have a lot of money
we're headed up river to agreement
cristal
i gotta be honest it's not a fun
vacation
but you're gonna beg me to turn back
10 000 to bring you there live dead it's
15 000.
why should i pay more dead
dead i'd have to carry you that's a lot
harder lady
here we go
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it's impossible